dolphin a piece of software used for
emulating GameCube and Wii games is
coming to steam this year the company
made the announcement in a blog post but
did not indicate an exact release date
for the emulator on valve's platform
however the store page says it's aiming
for a Q2 2023 release window and you can
wish list it right now dolphin will
launch for free in Early Access and its
developers aiming for the emulator to
launch in full by the end of 2023. the
full version will have better steam UI
support to make it easier to navigate
but the emulator will still contain the
quote full dolphin experience while in
Early Access now keep in mind dolphin
does not actually include games but it's
simply a tool utilized to play them the
open source software allows players to
run GameCube and Wii games that they
have obtained legally players will just
need to convert these games into a
compatible format to run them in the
Dolphin Emulator if you're more focused
on Nintendo's future games then you
might be excited for Legend of Zelda
tears of the Kingdom luckily for you the
game's development is complete this news
was delivered during the gameplay
showcase that premiered earlier today
March 28th in the 10 minutes of footage
Nintendo showed off the game's World
Combat and new abilities these abilities
include recall which link uses to
reverse a fallen Rock and ride it back
into the sky fuse allows link to create
makeshift weapons for materials in the
environment Ultra hand can be used to
join objects together to create vehicles
and lastly Ascend allows the link to
pass through ceilings marked by a
specific symbol I'm really excited to
explore all of the possibilities with
fuse but I'm also pretty nervous about
all of the possibilities with ultra hand
seeing as though when Gamers get
Crafting Tools in video games they
always tend to make one shape first and
uh I can already see it happening here
if you're worried about missing out on
tears of the Kingdom because you don't
have a switch or if you're just a
collector of the many Zelda themed
Nintendo consoles you're are going to
want to grab the special edition tears
of the Kingdom OLED model this switch
will cost 360 dollars while the special
edition Pro Controller is 75 and there's
also a carrying case for 25. all three
Zelda themed items should be available
for pre-order today and in other news
Ubisoft officially announced its next
Ubisoft forward event scheduled for June
12th at 10 A.M Pacific Time 1 pm Eastern
this news comes on the heels of Ubisoft
pulling out of e3 with the company
stating it has decided to move in a
different direction and holds its own
presentation there's no other details
yet but pass Ubisoft forward events have
been streamed through YouTube and twitch
how long the event will be is currently
unknown and it turns out that UB isn't
the only company leaving E3 behind this
week a new report from IGN States Sega
and tencent have also dropped out of the
event the site says that numerous people
in publishing in PR have expressed
concern about the status of E3 many of
whom felt that there has been a quote
significant lack of communication from
the esa and organizer read pop as to
what exactly they should expect from the
show personally I think we're not too
far off from the cancellation of e3 2023
I think in the next coming weeks we're
going to see some more reports of
companies dropping out and then in the
second half of April we're gonna get
that official announcement I don't see
them dragging it out too long especially
since it's supposed to take place in
June I just I can't imagine a world
where it's the end of May and we're
still pretending that this is gonna
happen but let me know your thoughts in
the comments section what do you think
the fate of e3 2023 is and we'll see you
tomorrow
thank you